how often do you think about basketball
how often said everyday now every day
because my daughter is playing and I
coach so I coach your team so we
practice every day and so okay are you
running the triangle we are we are we
are running the tribe we absolutely are
and they execute it beautifully no
kidding
beautifully I was messing with film so
the first time we rated triangle right
we ran a center opposite action mmm and
he ran it beautifully got a beautiful
open three knocked it down I said the
video to Phil feels like does that sit
opposite they actually read and I said
yes cuz I got a better coach 12 so
they're 12 see you running for 12 yards
yeah are you giving them reading
material for 12 year-old no are you
doing that film what I learned is like
it's you have to think clearly and how
you teach it you just go piece by piece
like it's my responsibility to try to
teach them the game and teaching the
fundamentals of the game most
importantly alright passing with the
left hand
right understand spacing being able to
shoot the ball properly finish out the
room properly just basics right instead
of throwing them everything at once you
just break it up once a month so are you
do you find yourself using phil isms
with the kids like you know I do but I
started doing that even later in my
career you know a lot of his
philosophies a lot of things that he's
taught me have really shaped Who I am
and that's why I think he's the greatest
coach because he impacted me not just
from a basketball perspective but you
know as a person so give me an example
what does he what does he left feeling
for patients I mean you remember me when
I was younger it was like yo do this do
it now let's go why aren't you getting
this come on let's go right as opposed
to now sitting back and allowing things
to materialize and allowing people and
to develop and find their own way and be
there simply as a guiding force which
helps me a lot in the coaching of my my
kids team helps me the storytelling a
lot as well for the podcasts of what you
got out there now you're talking about
like when when the stories are written
for these children's podcast the peonies
your are you going over the copy or you
like actually looking through what's
before yeah so like what out what I did
is
when the idea of the show first case we
had the two characters already created
which was puny P and B be labelled had
written ten short stories for them an
idea was to have them have individual
picture books with short stories but
then we have a family tradition where we
watch the satellite every four for July
and sanma every July we watch to sail
out as a family and after watching this
a last like man we need more movies like
this you know for kids it's just in a
park and having fun uh-huh so I start
kind of coming up with ideas and
concepts and nothing really stuck and
then in Thanksgiving all the tradition
is watching the peanuts you know
Thanksgiving special short right and so
when I was watching that
those two things just came together for
me was like wow I got it Huey P BB
LaBelle come together this is gonna be
yeah I'm gonna mix the SE lot and the P
and the peanuts and create our own
series well it's interesting you know
listening to some of the episodes of
this podcast the opening theme when I
heard it it sounded like the peanuts
that's our homage to the peanuts and
Schulz and whether what they were able
to create and I feel like in this day
and age for children the music is very
very pop it was always all of that
there's no classic music anymore of
strong piano themes and strong melody
themes and so we wanted to kind of go
back it's a way to the way shows used to
be so when it all comes down to it you
want to do what with your second career
here totally and we want to do is use
sports as the greatest metaphor for life
and if we feel we feel like if we can
teach kids how to deal with anxiety how
to deal with pressure how to deal with
failure how to deal with success through
sport that an intern helps them to
become better people right so like if
you're struggling with something if your
kids struggling with a bully at school
or struggling with taking tests cuz the
pressure is just too much how do you
practice that I guess as a father you
can go to your daughter and your son
didn't say okay you know work your
hardest don't worry about the end result
but those are just words aren't they
right they have to physically put
themselves emotionally put themselves in
that same situation over and over to
really be able to understand how to deal
with it and what we're saying is that
sports does that for you so now through
sport when you practice every day and
you're playing these games you have
these emotional challenges you get used
to figuring out how to navigate yourself
through which in turn helps you to
become a better test taker and vice
versa
I had Jeanie buss on my show last week
she'd said that you sent her text when
LeBron came to the Lakers of her as the
mother of dragons Khaleesi photograph
what was your intention I did I said
there a gift of Khaleesi riding in on
thousand ships behind her with Tyrion
next to her right I said this is what
you are I mean when I spoke to her about
making her decision I told us they could
at some point Jeannie you have to become
Khaleesi you got to be the mother of
dragons the decision later with her
family yeah you got a claim with his
rightfully yours go for it man so I felt
like that was appropriate to send her
that that give well she's now she kind
of does sit on that iron throne I guess
to use that phrase with LeBron coming
here what is your relationship with
LeBron I talked to him the the day it
was announced I've talked to him and
just reached out told her say welcome to
LA I said now you're part of the family
so if you ever need anything was whoever
just you know what finally man I'm right
here and it's excited for me are you
aware that are some of your diehard fans
that have an issue with LeBron being
termed as part of the family
yeah I hear that but you know listen if
you're a fan of mine and you're a fan of
winning you're a fan of the Lakers right
I believe purple and gold so that's
above anything else I'm gonna Laker fan
since I was yea high that's never going
to change right and we're spot winning
championships
so they'll fall in line what do you
think he needs to accomplish here in
order to be viewed in a similar vein as
say you as a Laker
Kobe well I don't know the me
comparisons of him being viewed in a
similar vein as million others mate what
sensor I mean I you know I think the
goal is always to win championships no
matter where you go that's the goal and
that's his goal that's Rob's goal that's
magic school that's Jeannie's goal Rondo
all the guys Kuzma lines or they all
want to win championships man so that's
what they're gunning for so he means to
win a championship here and a lot of
people why do people always say that
they say ok well you need to it and then
then there's this this light crowd of
people down like well you don't need to
win a champion well you asking me we
have to win championship this is why we
play this why we're here is to win
championships and if you want to came
here for you didn't expect to win
championships well I mean I'm of the
mindset that his legacy as one of the
all-time greats is already sealed
yeah and that that's kind of he's
already done that yeah you know you
would agree with that as I'm here
obviously right so now he's coming to
Los Angeles and in a way he's trying to
next level achieve with something you
already have which is Laker
championships flow and maybe an Oscar in
the trophy case also
well is it to me it's just really simple
wherever you play the object is to win
championships that's it end of story
end of story professional basketball how
often do you think about that these days
uh I mean every so often but not not
much not think about it for you know a
lot of that players reach out they want
to come out and work out and do some
things like that so I have guys come
down and I'll work with him who's come
whose Jason's been Jason's been down
Jason Takes the team's been down
kuzmin's been down have a couple more on
the books coming down later in the
summer what do you do with them guys
well we're not the first thing to do is
self assess what do you feel comfortable
doing on the court where you don't feel
comfortable going it starts with that
you got to be able to look inside and
say okay you know coaches can only tell
you but so much you know what you can
and can't do and you have to be honest
about it and so once we get to that then
that's okay well let's put you through
it sound of screws my look to you he
looks great man Luis gray he's got good
rhythm you know he has the ability to
disassociate movements
which gives him a fluidity when he plays
but he can shoot the ball he's worked on
his big rain game just came a lot post
up game looks strong so looking forward
to him having a good year how often do
you give your thoughts on the current
lake a roster to say your former agent
every every time Rob calls me okay you
you offer something up to him well yeah
I mean probably I've been friends for
ever these godfather to Gianna and so
we'll talk man and I'll sometimes I'll
call it just to check out and see how
he's doing you know because like you
know when I played during this season
he'd have to pick up for me with my
family
because I'd miss for example Halloween
Christmas sure and so he'd go off with
my family and stuff what was your agent
where's my agent no but now it's just
kind of reverse so when he's out on the
road I'll spend time with his family and
take him out trick or treat and all that
good stuff
but do you think of Rondo's presents
here with Lanza ball and him is there
and you think of competition in the back
corner no I think there's a lot to be
learned from me Rondo is a student of
the game how he studies the game feeling
somebody allows it can learn from you
know Rondo sit there and watch film for
hours and hours and hours and hours and
dissect them pick things apart to the
smallest of detail and I think it's
important for Lanza to see that also how
you facilitates the game how you reads
things happening before they actually
happen how you can manipulate the
defense to make things happen and also
defensively he gets after you mm-hmm
so I think it's great when I spoke to
Jeanne and she said that she would have
you do anything you'd like for the
Lakers franchise has she communicated
that to ya okay she has even a rumor
that you might consider even maybe
coming out of retirement to play one
more time for the Lakers right I see
you're laughing yeah there's nothing to
that right there's about a 0% chance
that I come back and play so not even
like a nothing zero you're toast
you're finished done as a player that's
it did last year at any point with you
going through your first season not
playing basketball never not once did
you've ever got it never anything is for
us athletes is really hard to transition
from that right and I was really
personal about it when I wrote dear
basketball but that is the truth
challenge of finding what comes next I
find some that you love to do every bit
as much as you love your first passion
that is a challenge for us and I think
fortunately for us athletes we've been
pigeon holder there thinking that we can
only be one thing so when I retired
everybody is saying okay he's too
competitive he's not gonna know what to
do with himself he's gonna have to come
back I took that as a personal challenge
of them thinking I'm this
one-dimensional person all that knows
how to dribble the ball shoot the ball
and play basketball and compete at that
level let's not take it as a personal
challenge I will never come back to the
game ever I'm here to show people that
we can do much more than that
and creating this business winning an
Oscar and I mean Andy those are things
that are showing other athletes that
come after no no there's more to this
thing okay so I wouldn't never it's not
even know not even a thought something
keep the goal so he got you want the
Emmy the Grammy the honor the challenge
became how do I take the lessons that I
learned through the game of basketball
and translate them into building a
studio right where do things that I can
take from that to discipline the
commitment the team and community how do
you get the best out of each other how
do I take those lessons and move those
here that is the challenge how do we do
great work uncompromising great work not
looking at the bottom line and focus on
the product first right is this the best
thing that we can possibly make no
matter what egg having that sharp focus
is something that I got from the game of
basketball
so the now what a podcasts I mean how
four children what how do you choose
your projects have it how does that
process go for you well I just you know
sit and I'll think and I'll create you
know I write them all out
and create the characters create the
rules the structure and and then you
kind of got to go with your gut you got
go with your gut and see are we creating
something that's been done before or is
this surprising something that nobody's
seen before and is it a project that
we're not sure that we can do if the
answer is yes then nine times out of ten
we're going for that one
alright cuz that means we're pushing
boundaries a little bit so that's how I
generally pickle get one act no no I
love creating I love creating I love
directing a lot producing I don't love
acting I don't love being in front of
the camera I like trying to figure out
the arc of the story is the right one
sure are you taking pitches no you don't
take pitches don't nobody's pitching
Kobe Bryant is still wrong we all take
pitches like we're very focused company
like we have our projects that's laid
out five years you know exactly we're
releasing from now two five years from
now and when we're releasing them and
how they have a domino effect from books
to film to a Broadway we have very
specific goals things that we want to
accomplish so we're very very focused on
those and all the projects are created
in-house so coming to you with my dear
TV idea that's that's out that's not
happening I mean if I ever need well you
kind of just slipped it in there right
now so I'll take that as a pitch well I
mean not just I'm not done with my
career
you're not saying at some point dear TV
dear TV listen I can always you know
dust thoughts okay you don't like it I
can dust off the pin and edit it for you
you write it to me and if you don't you
won't Maps already notes you'll circle I
will okay in the meantime you're just
gonna be like you said you're more
patient now what happened to the
patient's cold no you know I see there's
another level that you can okay wouldn't
you agree why yes I agree with that
cutsies that would let's focus on being
our best self okay and then the meantime
you're just gonna coach your coaching
your daughters I am fantastic
yes and that's what twice a week three
times a week you know what at all every
day every day every day is there a love
our type parent that you're dealing no
no fortunately all of our parents are
very patient and just kind of hands-off
with their children no just take their
kids to Lithuania no no
not yet no no yeah Aiko thank you very
much I appreciate it good to see you
thank you Kobe Bryant here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience